facebook page
facebook.com slash book tv
always right and cody you can actually
hold the mic okay
okay
well thank you everybody for coming um
uh if you hadn't noticed uh
uh c-span book tv is gonna be here
recording tonight um so during the q a
portion
um i'll be passing this microphone
around so we can make sure we get that
captured along with the rest of the talk
um
we are book culture is so pleased uh to
host louis laughing tonight in
conversation with terry mcdonnell
the new book the age of folly out by
verso press
and uh terry mcdonald's new book also uh
the accidental life and editor's notes
on writing and writers we have uh plenty
of copies up front and we encourage you
to pick up one or two or three
so that way we can continue to be a
community space here on the upper west
side a quick show of hands if
you've been here before
okay well welcome uh all the new faces
um 20 years ago this was the end of cop
book sellers um but was lost to the
upper west side with many other
wonderful independent bookstores over
the years but a couple years ago
book culture and partnership with
harper's magazine opened up this space
in order to celebrate the important
written word that
might not always get the attention it
deserves
and something that we think an
independent bookstore
can offer more than anyone else
and again we're really happy to be here
to be able to bring great authors in
for a great conversation
um
and
lewis lapham is the founding editor of
latin's quarterly editor mayor of
harper's magazine uh and his columns
received the national magazine award in
1995 for exhilarate or for exhibiting an
accelerating point of view in an age of
conformity
and in 2002 the thomas paine journalism
award
he was inducted into the american
society of magazine editors hall of fame
in 2007 and his other books include
money in class in america fortune's
child imperial masquerade among other
titles
terry mcdonnell has won numerous awards
for his editorial work at various
magazines and websites he's also a
novelist and a poet has written and
produced
for film and television
and in 2012 he was inducted to the
american society of magazine editor's
hall of fame uh he's the president
of the board of the paris review
foundation and serves on the board of
overseers of the columbia journalism
review
so thank you everybody for coming and
i'll go ahead and turn over to our
office
[Music]
i believe he turned it over to me lewis
and that's the signal for the round of
applause
let me let me start by giving you a
little background on my relationship
with lewis
the uh
just so you know you'll know
uh
lewis is the has been
for my entire working life
the
role model
he's an
archetypical heroic figure for
all freewheeling editors
and all careful writers
it was a true thing
he uh we grew up in the same place
really except
his his father was the mayor
and his grandfather had founded standard
oil
and i was
picking apricots
down in the valley
but enough about me
uh specifically what what was so
important to me and to almost everyone
that i have ever worked with as an
editor
is the uh
the
the revolutionary thinking that lewis
did about what that meant and what his
magazines were like we we went to school
on them at harper's when he invented the
index that was a way to tell a story
that had never been used before
statistical data put ironically into a
particular order that told you more
about your moment in the country than
all the 20 000 word pieces that we were
trying to bring in and then there were
the readings etc anyway this is just
it's so important i can't tell you and
and we follow him
still through you know lapham's
quarterly which is also revolutionary
kind of a publication so his his career
is this arc really from
the rockets and newspaper days in san
francisco through the
the
the high points of the new journalism i
would
recommend that you all find or look up
lewis's piece about being with the
beatles
in the 60s
when the beatles were seeking
not redemption or were they seeking
enlightenment with the maharishi now
lewis has a point of view about that if
you read this book you'll enjoy that all
the way through to the digital upheavals
that we have going on now which he is
surfing like
like uh
the hoe daddy that he is
and it's a wonderful wonderful book um i
i just i think what i'd like to do is
start with the
the first paragraph of the book lewis
in which you suggest that after
you have to go before you buy the book
or they're gonna make you buy the book
read that first paragraph in the book on
your way out and you'll be sold anyway
in the heart of the paragraph you
suggest that donald trump is not a
surprise
really
true
that's that's the point i mean donald
trump has been
walking down the road toward
his
nomination for the presidency of the
united states in the year 2016.
according to the i mean it's the way
it's been going for for 25 years and and
the
the book is a series of essays
that were written over the course of the
25 years from 1990
2015
setting up the the premise
of that
generalization
so you have
in 1991 you have george
president george h.w bush
staging the
or sending the gunboats
to
iran in the what was the second gulf war
sending the gun votes and the cameras to
display
with self-congratulatory explosives
the great making america great again
that was what he was essentially
attempting to do
the united states was caught
or the washington
consensus was caught off guard by the
coming down of the berlin wall in 1989
and the
implosion of the
evil soviet empire
this was something that had never been
predicted
either by the
thinkers in the pentagon
or
the
uh
the thinkers
writing for the new york review of books
but let me interrupt you with that yeah
that's the point in time and you're
thinking but here comes trump
i'm thinking here comes trump because
what it is is
self-congratulatory explosions
in the in the persian gulf in 1991
really to simply
advertise the greatness of the great
american empire
and what you've got with trump
is
self-congratulatory
uh
bursts of
bombast bursting in air
i mean it's the same kind of it's the
same kind of see that's in that first
paragraph it's the same kind of
self-promotion i mean and and uh
and trump is is uh
he's in the news in in 1989 i mean he's
opened his trump tower but why do you
wait why do you think the republicans
didn't see this coming
like
the republicans got
caught up in the dream of of of glory of
the dream of american empire the dream
of that there was nobody else in the
world
that mattered except the united states
the american way was the right way
and that
any
impertinent nation that that had
that refused to see it
it was it was
it was our obligation to destroy those
people
i mean that's the what was called the
national defense strategy for the 1990s
published in 1993
written by dick cheney
and paul wolfowitz
and it sets out very clearly the
doctrines of preempted strike and
forward deterrence
commits the united states to maintain
two major wars on two continents
at any one time
and to
take out
any any country that any nation any
failed state
that
doesn't wish to accept the
the american guidance
guidance guidance and this is also the
same here if you've got to remember that
that uh
uh god was the guy's name the the guy
that wrote the book the end of history
the great guru
you know i mean
yeah fukiyama fukiyama is talking about
the end of history same year 1989 1990
that the american way is the only way
it's established the world of you know
that the competition of ideas is over
soviet union has collapsed
and the only thing left to do
is is maintenance of the
perfection
of the american idea you also write in
the book that we've lost our grasp of
the american tradition of of uh
revolutionary thinking
a revolutionary spirit you call it
i mean yes this is contradictory to me
terry i mean the thing that's startling
is you know when i
began putting these essays together
starting in 1991 and and bringing it
forward to 2016
is how little
the thinking has changed
i mean we we
talk about era of
spectacular change technology silicon
valley
uh
robots i mean and so forth but the
the thinking in in in washington the
so-called washington consensus has not
changed
at all well you also say that that our
history
is a resource because you are a
historian you say it's a great resource
and that we are squandering it
we are i mean that's the reason that i
left harper's magazine in 2000 and
six seven in order to start the lapis
quarterly which is a
deal which is about history
and i think that of history as an
immensely
generative
uh
source of
of hope energy and ideas
also irony
as a reader of the lab yeah well i heard
quarterly
irony irony is simply the lessons of
experience terry that's all ah
irony is not a the lessons of experience
yes yeah
well but no i i think history is is
enormously
valuable
you want me to say at one point in the
book that the uh that our our satirists
are not playing with fire the way they
should be playing with fire
well explain yourself there
no they're not playing with fire in the
same way that uh
well
actually i'm borrowing that idea from
mark twain
but
twain
looked at
says satire
as a form of arson
to to burn down the
hospitality tents
of
self-congratulatory cant
that was running you guys get that
sentence
yeah burn down
the self congratulations the hospitality
the hospitality intensive
self-congratulatory
can't
that's i'm pretty much quote we all need
this book
you know i'm riffing on twain there yeah
i mean he thought satire as the crime
of arson and that was what it was
intended
to do
and he was an adult
and
when he as he turned more uh
uh
he had
began to have more edge
as he got older
he didn't publish some of his
most acerbic commentary
because it would hurt his
you know
public persona as as the friendly
garrulous
man in a white suit right
so it wasn't a lot of it wasn't
published until after his death
and then only over the
strenuous objections of his daughters
who were afraid that
the posthumous publication of uh
twain's most bad biting satire would
uh
destroy his his reputation but the
but then but he never let anybody off
the hook i mean and and the thing is
with with our
kinds of satire or the kind of satire
that's become you know saturday night
live and
uh
john
stewart and
so on
they let us off the hook because they
say it's all a joke
we're all in the know
okay we've got crooks running the bus
the government
not only crooks but
unbelievably stupid incompetence i mean
our our
our military is
is is a
disaster i mean we we present
our military i mean the media the big
media presents it as uh
the most powerful force
in the world
charles krauthammer in in the year 2000
2001
four months before the attack on the
trade towers
and time magazine says
america is the most powerful military
the most powerful nation
since since imperial rome
the world will be bent to our will i
mean i'm quoting
but this was the on d this is the
consensus of opinion in washington
now the point is that our military and
and we start off with the invasion of
iraq again in 1993
expecting a walk in the park
uh expecting to transform the whole of
the middle east
into connecticut
and and and the uh
to do this with the most magnificent
military force ever assembled in in the
history of the world i mean this is
every editorial in the new york times
this is the
paid you know this is uh
network news television and so on the
truth is the united states
hadn't won a war
and well hadn't fought a war in uh
45 years hadn't won a war in 70 years
i mean our american military essentially
is is show business it's an
advertisement we we do
uh
we make war movies louis yeah you watch
television
not very often
well how i mean how do you get how do
you get how are you informed
if you're not watching like
the
the campaign coverage on television
are you not watching some of that i've
watched some of it but you don't have to
see a lot of it i mean you get the idea
really really really quite early i mean
it it's the uh
you know i i i saw trump
come down the you know the deus ex
machina in june 2015
when he comes down the
escalator
in the atrium of the trump tower and
announces himself as
candidate for the united states okay i
mean for the next for the presidency
that was his
announcement
okay
now that this
you ask me how things have been coming
at us for the last 25 years and trump's
no surprise
okay if you saw that which i did
on
on television
it's almost
exactly
george
w bush
on the
deck of the united states carrier uss
abraham lincoln may 1st 2004
sorry 2003
saying
mission accomplished
right
it's the same kind of deus ex mackinac
appearance i mean he comes out of a
fighter jet wearing a costume
in uh
you know top gun costume
swaggers up to the microphone and says
missions is accomplished
we had already lost the war in terror on
three months after we started it
the war had begun in march of 2003
with a magnificent airshow
over baghdad
this is this dropped more munitions on
it
this sounds like a saturday night live
skit louis
it's not a scattering light but i'm
pointing it out because i think that
that kind of that kind of satire is
effective
on television now yes but they saved the
trouble with the television is
they saved that kind of satire until two
years later
nobody was saying that
in the media in 2003 the media was
comparing bush and the united states
army and
to to uh
you know
the americans at d-day
they were comparing the american
generals to
to rommel
i mean
the i mean the the
the hype
god i mean
but
what's the guy's name at cnn he was he
was going to put you mean wolf blitzer
no no no the you know
the guy that was going to carry a gun
and go personally to toropora
and and gunned down
uh
bin laden right
i don't do anyone know what
i find that questions in the middle
sometimes
shake things up anybody have any
questions
those
yes
thank you for your thoughts so far
the only problem i have with this
analysis is that it's very easy to be
wise after the event i'm sorry the only
problem i have with this analysis that
it's very easy to be wise after the
event no but the point of the book is
it's on the event these are essays that
are printed
exactly
as it happens right i'm not writing this
25 years later i am writing it then
no no i appreciate that but i was just
um sort of in terms of how all of this
plays into trump
i mean the thing is that you know in the
years and months and years after the
infamous carrier incident um
that
sort of display of power came to be
ridiculed right it's not necessarily a
linear narrative that we go from there
no no
you're misunderstanding it it's it i'm
not following trump for 25 years i'm
following the
self-congratulatory attitude
of the american
uh
so-called washington consensus of the
of the uh the republican party
of the neoconservative
sense of american empire
i mean the
the the notion of american
great again the notion that america can
do with anything that god damn well
pleases in the world
the trumpian arrogance
and actually
stupidity
has been
characteristic
of the way that we have been managing
our
government and foreign policy and
military for for 25 years
that's all i'm saying i'm not no i'm i'm
not following trump i mean i
i met trump in 1989
and once was enough
and the sensibility was
pervasive
i mean it was a
systematic
um
and it's in the second paragraph in the
book i i
i go back to uh aristotle
and aristotle is talking about
uh this
the way
forms of government
follow one another democracy monarchy
despotism
and so on right it's a circle
and what he says is that all governments
all governments start off as oligarchies
a relatively a relative few
people with the with the money in the
society
attempt to set up a a uh
a government
it's a it's a it's what the founders of
the united states were setting up trying
to set up in washington and sorry in
philadelphia in 1787.
madison says that madison says we are
trying to establish a government
that will be run by people with the
wisdom to discern and the virtue to
pursue the common good of the society
that's a direct quote
the people who sign the constitution are
all rich they're the merchant rich from
the northeast
and the plantation rich from the south
and they are undertaking
to provide a a
a government a constitution
that will allow
balance
the the
a democratic
society with a capitalist consumer
economy
and those two things are very different
a democracy democratic society values
equality
it's the motions of the heart
the capitalist economy
has no interest in equality
none
it's about more for me and less for you
and goodbye and good luck that's trump
lewis what do you uh is that what you
mean by what you call the deliberate
imprecision of the constitution yes
they're trying to set up that balance
they're trying to balance the motions of
the heart with the movements of the
market
so they're very successful and they do
that
but the trouble with that is it takes
a continued paying of attention
on the part of the of the people who are
managing
that
form of government
they were trying to set up
a republic
and
republics last
only as long as the people that are
engaged in it
really work at it
and the
and pay attention
but
that doesn't happen sooner or later and
our this is aristotle again it's not me
it's aristotle it's also madison
sooner or later
all oligarchies turn
rancid
they get
they're like cheese they go bad in the
sun because as well accumulates
the men decay
that is
you can see that all the way that
happens all the i mean
that happens in greece that happens in
rome that happens in
in the austin regime in france and it
happens in the united states
people
the greeks called it the disease was
called
pleonexia
which is the disease that imagines that
there is nothing that money can't buy
and at leonixia is the desire for more
more of everything
more dancing girls
more cruise missiles
more floors on the buildings on
57th street more circulation more more
of everything
and the uh
the greeks call that pleonexia and they
call that the disease that the
the idea that there is nothing that
money can't buy and the united states
falls into that disease
in spades i mean i mean the uh
i mean
across the
a couple of hundred years of america's
existence i mean
there have been
many struggles with that that's the
struggle that
jackson has with the banks
in the in the 1830s that's the struggle
of the progressive
populist parties rising at the end of
the 19th century that's
you know
the country
crucified on the cross of gold that's
william jennings brian that's
part of the
what's in teddy roosevelt's mind when
he's picking an argument with the trust
it's the same thing that's in the mind
of
of
franklin d roosevelt
when he's putting together the
the new deal i mean
this is a constant struggle
lewis writes in the book that is a quote
the foretelling of the apocalypse never
loses its appeal
as we have just heard from lewis
no it never appears loses its appeal i
mean they
but preachers in in in
puritan massachusetts
would get up
and and
when they were
speaking from the pulpit
they would actually
they learned to to cry
like you know actors and and wiping the
tears from their eyes
because of the
sins of the world that had been visited
upon
the congregation
in in cambridge
and the world was coming to an end
jonathan edwards sinners in the hands of
an angry god
but the priests would actually i mean
sorry preachers what it would actually
learn to weep
tears i mean you know they we
like the columns of david brooks i mean
it it it's this it's the the uh
it's
yeah you say the columns of david broder
or brooke brooks
i mean that's an idea the world is going
no the what the idea is the world is
going to hell i mean you know i mean
well is it though
no
good news
it's not going into any more hell and
it's been through
many many times before you have no idea
how reassuring that is to me it should
be i mean yeah well no that's one of the
great values of history no but here we
are on the brink of the election of what
right
yeah the two most unpopular candidates
right in history of the republic right
well i'll just stop there and ask you
what you make of that
well we they're lack of popular whatever
it that is
well it it it might persuade uh
enough people in the country look like
those in this room
the people essentially who own the
country and
to pay attention to politics
i mean for for the last
30-yard years i mean people
who have a stake in the country who own
you know
people who
run the banks and and so forth and so on
uh
people that enjoy the the privileges of
american citizenship
have had almost no interest
in politics they've been perfectly happy
to leave it to the hired help
who cares who wants to go to why i mean
as you
and i both know terry and
there are a lot of very talented
interesting intelligent thoughtful
courageous
people
in the united states
but they don't go into politics
what was it in your background that kept
you from entering the arena
kept me from entering the arena no i'm
just saying there's got to be some
horrible skeleton that would they would
have come to come out if you're running
for the senate
no no
i actually entertained the thought at
one point but very briefly i mean
well tell
well
as you know my
grandfather was the mayor of san
francisco during world war ii
and i often accompanied him on his
rounds as mayor and i also
as the mayor of san francisco in 1945
he was
obliged to preside over the
formation of the charter of of the
united
nations how old were you 10.
and so he excused me from school
and i had to go to the plenary sessions
of the
formation of the u.n in in
1945.
also
during the course of the war
the
the mayor
would be obliged to
go out in a launch and meet the
returning
carriers coming in from the war in the
pacific so at the age of nine
i was being
piped aboard the enterprise and
introduced to admiral
nimitz or admiral halsey and that makes
a very big impression on a nine-year-old
did you have a little short pants on
[Laughter]
and beside that grandfather was was a
very
unconventional
politician he'd been a
ship owner
during the 30s we had a
we had a
family had a shipping company
and the
and
he ran for mayor on the ground that he
would serve one term and one term only
and that he would
make all the decisions
to do what what he thought
ought to be done and what was right
twice during his four-year
term
the machine politicians tried to impeach
him
because he really
did a lot of damage to the to the uh the
machine politics in the city
and
both times
he was
restored with with a higher uh
majority
and the uh
he was a very popular mayor and and he
did
he tried to stay absolutely
uh fixed on on his civic purpose and the
uh
and at the end
they said to him well jesus yeah i mean
you could run for governor and and he
said no i made one deal and that's it
so i had that kind of an idea and and
the um
so i thought okay i'd
start out in the in the newspaper
business in in san francisco and learn
something and about
politics and then i would come to new
york and i would learn something about
journalism and
work for a big time newspaper and
meet people like you terry
but then i would go back to california
and and uh
and and
possibly
you know attempt to get elected senator
i actually had that idea right
but then i i
um
well then
well a lot of different things happened
but but the uh
one of them was i was married to a woman
who had absolutely no
interest or willingness to you know play
the part of it the part of a
wife of a politician is horrible and the
uh
i wouldn't put her through it
so what lewis did instead
was stayed in the east coast and began
to mock
the west coast
mock i know this because i was reading
all this time
did you not
i wrote one
[Laughter]
well yes i i yeah
because it was because this is such a
good place to live as a person of
letters and ideas
that was that was your point no
no my my point was
the pasta i don't think no no the part
the the point came out of my experience
as a san francisco examiner i'm i'm on
the san francisco examiner
in 19
uh
let's see it's my last year so it's
1959.
and there was a mistake the
examiners are hearst paper
but there was also a los angeles
examiner also a hurst paper
and their sunday rota reviewer sections
magazine sections in those tables were
both published uh printed in bakersfield
rota revere was it was an old publishing
uh a printing uh technology that
required you to print
six weeks
was it not before the deadline yeah it
was
you were way behind oh yeah right and
the uh
you know it was newsprint it wasn't
glossy like new york times magazine and
the uh
so
but they mixed it up the
they put
the story
at 12 page spread with photographs
that was intended to be in the los
angeles acc
paper
they'd put the
cover of the san francisco paper on it
so sunday morning comes in san francisco
papers you know we have the paper and it
says
los angeles it's san francisco examiner
los angeles the athens of the west
and
san francisco is a very uh
self-satisfied town how is this your
fault lewis not my fault
it's not my fault but you were blamed
for it you've told me no i was playing
i'll tell you why i was blamed for it
because i
so we have this horrible thing we have
los angeles
the athens of the west and then there
are 12 pages photographs
bella bartok is still alive thomas mon
christopher isherwood igor stravinsky
morris lewis raymond chandler long list
all in la the la brat pack at the time i
guess that was a pretty big time brass
pack
and the uh
and i came i was a young reporter so i
was the first person in on
at 10 o'clock on monday morning on
sunday morning
and all the brass the paper was there
the managing editor the publisher
and
they had gathered around the coffee
table and they were looking at this
thing
and it was an attitude of i thought
a cruise ship
had sunk
and and a thousand were dead in the bay
i mean it had that kind of crisis
and they brought me over and they said
this is heresy
san francisco is the athens of the west
everybody knows that right
and and
you
will write
for tomorrow's paper the monday paper
banner headline
no no
san francisco is the athens
okay
and i i'm given
it's 10 30 in the morning and i have the
deadline's four in the afternoon
and i have to back up that headline
right it couldn't be done
i mean
henry miller was in
big sur
okay the
evan canal was in sausalito
that was the ball game
there was nobody in san francisco the
opera was
roadshow the theater was roadshow new
york
there was no
serious music there was
some jazz but that was
the modern jazz quartet but but they
were
they weren't rooted in san francisco the
beat generation had left
by that time uh the
the the
so i mean i i came to the uh
vanishing editor at four o'clock and i
said
i for one sir do not believe that there
is an athens to the west
but if there is
it is in los angeles
[Laughter]
and i was fired
you were twitter to your class
you know your grandfather was mayor you
know and so on and the uh
and so they assigned the story to a
imprisoned journalist 35 years old
mortgage three children no choice
to write the story and he wrote it and
he simply attributed it to it
quotes from
louis luery
owner
of a
flashy restaurant of course san
francisco is the athens of the west
second quote from cyril magnan owner of
magnus department store
no question san francisco is the athens
of the west
third quote was from herb kane
bag died by the bay
i was going to throw that in i wonder if
anybody knew what that was god
i mean that you know that
and that to me basically is the what
is the way the media works
yourself being set but that's that's
that's what the
you know that our our our national news
media is set up to
to
show that our armies are invincible and
and
and and so on right
to paint the
paint the rosy picture on on on the uh
on the on the
you know the
it's an advertisement for reality
that's the status quo i mean and but
that's natural that's what the media is
supposed to do let me
just
round this up by asking you what you're
going to do on election night
what what are you going to do in
election night
i'm assuming i'm going to watch it
quietly and at home
with my wife and the uh
you got to vote
am i going to vote no
i'm not going to vote
my vote does not count barry please
let's let's not go through that the
it's in the book louis it's in the book
yeah i have a quote here okay
numbers suggest that maybe the people
who don't vote have good and sufficient
reasons
for their abstentions right also in in
new york in the city of new york i mean
the electoral college is
democratic i mean the reason that
the politicians don't bother to come and
talk to anybody in new york is because
it's it's a you know it doesn't matter
who i vote for it will be
the new york
state is is is uh democratic
they're only whatever they are six swing
states in the whole united states where
the vote actually made count so we we
should drive to north carolina and buy
ourselves some
what a lottery
no i'm kidding let's go to some
questions
yeah
um thank you lewis for uh the talk
um
my my question goes back to your
statement about history being important
and as eisenhower said
warned us of the military industrial
complex
and
when jack kennedy
was in the white house
he was trying to negotiate with the
russians
to
calm down
the cold war
and
the military
it seems to me
wanted to ramp up in vietnam
and
approximately 48 hours after
jack kennedy was
killed
johnson uh put an order through to put
the troops into vietnam
and i'm wondering if the business of
america
isn't really the business of war
and the war machine
and it started there and as jim garrison
said
if this crime
is not properly investigated
the republic will not hold
your thoughts
well i i think that's largely true i
mean the the uh
uh i'm not a conspiracy theorist but but
the uh
the bone and marrow of of the
american economy
is the military-industrial complex and
and
that
and eisenhower was right about that
and the uh
that has what you know
sustained
the american
economy through the second half of the
uh
20th century on the
that is the reason in 1991
you know now comes the cold war
the russians comes down the coal you
know the
soviet union collapses
berlin wall comes down and this is why
it's such a
major event in washington because
they've been using the cold war
to
build
and constantly
build up the
military-industrial complex right
and you know how that works i mean they
got contracts in in every state
and so on and
and
it's not just the
military budget it's also the
contractors it's also the
corporations it's the
the arsenal of freedom right i mean
i don't know what it is today but
general electric one of the greatest uh
arms manufacturers in the country owns
nbc i mean i don't know if they still do
what they did
but essentially they own them
the same people are on the media and the
uh
so so yes
uh on the uh i feel like i'm on talk
radio between these two
no but i mean but a lot of people have
said this this is not this is not a
radical
point of view i mean
oliver stone wrote the whole book along
that line but
so did john appleton williams in the in
in the 60s i mean
so did the guy who i can't remember his
name but the general
who wrote war as a racket in in in the
in the 20s and 30s was an american
colonel
who who was
running our
wars in in
you know for a united fruit company in
in guatemala and honduras and then the
yes i mean and our wars have been
elective
i mean
we were attacked
in in world war ii
but all the other american wars have
been our choice
mexican war
right
war against the indians in in the in the
19th century
spanish-american war
korean war
vietnam war
our choice
and and the uh
yes i mean so
the uh
and there is a very fine book actually
that that
again other people have said this i'm
not
a talk show
you know
radical but there's a very fine book
that was published last
spring by a guy named andrew bessevich
it was called america's war for the
greater middle east
and he tells the story of
our
picking that fight
in 1980 jimmy carter
desert one if you remember
the helicopter that had come to rescue
the iranian
i mean
i i also have
and that book is is
marvelous and goes into very very
specific detail
i also had a a
a godfather
i mean again it's another point of
reference
my
godfather was a man named torquel rieber
he was a very good friend of my
grandfather
and
river was a norwegian he'd run away to
sea
uh
even
my family was in the texas oil business
texaco not standard oil and and the
reverb became the first tanker captain
of the first
texas tanker 1910 sailing out of
brownsville
texas and by 1930
he was chairman of the board of texas
and the
mexico was
as what a lot of other
american companies you know
dealing with the germans all the way
through the 30s and and the
texas oil was supplying
fuel to the
uh
german condor squadrons that were
at work in spain
and and the um
by 1950
3
rieber was the uh
you know the grand old man of the of the
of the american oil business he'd been
part of the
people that had set up a ramco
in in saudi arabia in
50s and the uh
and the americans were having trouble
with uh
masadek in iran right
democratically elected
president of that country
but that but he was
threatening to take the oil business
nationalize the oil
to take it back from the from the from
the british i mean it had been anglo
british american oil i mean british
british oil
and rieber was called down to washington
and told to go to
bring mozza deck a message
and the message was
mr masadek you either give us the oil or
we kill it
that simple
so your answer
is yes i mean there's a lot of you know
i don't
got him i mean there are a lot of people
that have have written books on on
various angles of this but yes
america is a war making country
and we have been for a long time take
another quick question
you are highlighted
mr laven you
highlight the
arrogance and stupidity the
neo-conservative
arrogance and stupidity
um
uh
particularly
embodied in donald trump
but what are your thoughts on the
arrogance and stupidity the neoliberal
arrogance oh it's the same i mean it it
i mean i don't make that much of it
i i don't make that much of a
distinction between
neoliberal neo-liberal and
neo-conservative the the um
and if you read the book i mean you will
see that you know it goes across
25 years and i have just as many
uh
observations of the
uh
clinton and and and the neoliberals as i
do of the
the the bush and the neoconservative i
mean
i mean as far as i know the the uh
hillary uh
clinton seems to be
part of the washington convences which
which has
been there
for a long time and it's it's
nonpartisan
can i can i close this out with a remark
of my own
you have any more questions
yes
uh yeah um i had a question more so uh
you said you're not a you said you're
not a conspiracy theorist i'm sorry you
said you're not a conspiracy theorist
but um donald trump certainly seems to
be
and i feel like what he has brought
about more so for me that's concerning
is um
him
questioning the rigging of the elections
every time someone brings up a fact he
comes up with something else that's
maybe not
backed up and that's something that
i don't know if it's internet culture or
if that's the future of you know because
everyone has their own echo chamber and
i feel like that is
what
i'm most concerned about uh going
forward for
future politicians
i really didn't understand that question
because i i had a hard time hearing you
because of the way the microphone was
are you asking me
what what do i think is happening next i
don't know
right just uh
um don't use the microphone the reverb
is is what is jumbling it uh just the
democratization of facts and conspiracy
theories uh because of the internet you
think the internet is bad for democracy
yes
i mean it makes it very hard to to
democracy is is about uh
about people face to face right
and the trouble with the in
the kind of argument you can have in
this
in a room this size right
madison again talks about democracy it
has to necessarily be
small and it has to be small enough
so that
the various people within it
of different walks
of
talents
ages and so on i mean this is
thomas payne's idea of democracy and it
was maybe possible
in the united states in in
1800 or 3 million people in the united
states
women don't have the vote blacks don't
have the vote
people without sufficient property don't
have the vote
and the and the people that are are
the
small oligarchy that
madison is talking about they can talk
to each other right
with the internet people
are departing from one another literally
at light speed i mean you know they can
live in their own little world they they
don't have to
hear anybody that disagrees with them
they don't have to
try to
compromise
you know they don't have to
here they are and they're in their own
self-confirming universe right
and and democracy's about friction it's
about change it's about argument it's
it's
it's it's not
a safe place
it's a very hard thing to pull off and
it depends on friction
even as
democracy depends upon the free flow of
information
yeah yeah
okay
okay here's my but the trouble the
internet it
drives people into
you know
many many different little
worlds of their own and it's hard to
you know
get that
moving in one direction
here's my story
and with this lewis is a great great
golfer
he doesn't brag about this he's a very
very fine scratch golfer has been for
years and years plays quite often
um when i was at sports illustrated
i met donald trump because of his
interest in golf and golf courses
and
donald trump cheats at golf
the other the only the other politician
who's famous for cheating at golf
is bill clinton
uh
this
little bit of information i impart to
you to similarly underline the fact that
lewis's book
has that kind of fun
with conservatives liberals radicals or
whatever it arches over the whole thing
to point out really who's cheating
it's a great book
should we thank mr lapham
[Applause]
thank you everybody
um we're going to real quick uh
move the speakers up to the front for
signing so if everybody could give us
maybe 10 seconds to get moved before you
all get up that would be appreciated
thank you
you ready to go
[Music]
this is book tv on c-span 2.